we traveled the country as a network
covering the midterm elections
and one thing I heard quite a bit was
our leaders are failing us when it comes
to
guns what do you say to that
well I look what I what I believe is is
that right now
uh
the Congress in particular is
stuck deadlocked on this issue
and so the question is all right what
can we do in the meantime even as we
continue to fight those fights and raise
awareness and start reshaping uh public
attitudes around this
um now part of that work has to be done
not just in those communities that
already want to do something about gun
violence we have to also actively Reach
Out
to communities where
gun ownership is is an important
tradition